[Musique]
et à lester jones bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous boris johnson qui dément donc
avoir participé à une fête en en mai
2020 son ancien conseiller dominique
kumming c1 la cus pourtant l'ami le
cerveau de sa campagne devenu finalement
son pire ennemi comment être sûr que que
l'on n'est pas ici dans une histoire de
basse vengeance
il s'agit probablement d'une vengeance
mais cela ne veut pas dire que ce n'est
pas vrai de munich à minsk a affirmé
qu'il jurerait sous serment tout ce
qu'il a dit est vrai
cela suggère qu'il a d'autres
informations dont nous ne sommes pas
encore au courant
cette situation tourne à la comédie pour
restions saint-aignan avoir participé à
une fête puis l'a dit il ya peut-être un
des fers un total n'était n'allait pas à
l'encontre des règles et puis il a lancé
une enquête pour voir s'il y avait eu
des dt rassemblement ce donc sa position
devant une fusion de plus le fragile et
à ces accusations par dominique comics
ne font qu'aggraver la chose un
peut-être que dominique commins est prêt
à témoigner sous serment mais boris
johnson aussi finalement est ce que ça
pourrait lui il lui coûter son poste
si on savait qu'il allait mais ça
s'avérait qu'il avait menti bien sûr un
s'il ya la moindre preuve que boris
johnson a menti au parlement alors il
devra démissionner où il sera chassé de
son poste c'est le pire des ligues que
l'on puisse commettre en tant que
premier ministre que de mentir au
parlement
il a menti à la population c'est certain
il a même menti l arène donc son bilan
et qu'ils m'ont souvent
cela a été prouvé dans ces emplois
précédents en tant que journaliste en
tant que maire de londres ainsi qu'en
tant que secrétaire des affaires
étrangères et en tant que député donc il
a déjà par le passé manipuler la vérité
afin de se faire bien paraître
il affirmé il s'agissait de réunions de
travail je ne sais pas si parmi les
téléspectateurs
beaucoup amènent leurs femmes à une
réunion de travail on boit de l'alcool
dans le jardin de sa maison pour moi
c'est
vraiment judicieux
et l'opinion générale qu'il a menti
qu'on l'a découvert et qu'il ne devrait
pas trop rester longtemps premier
ministre après cela pour l'opinion
britannique
c'est majeur justement de savoir si
boris johnson a dit oui a menti oui ou
non a dit la vérité ou finalement on va
à l'épinglé pour d'autres raisons costa
et ça a été la goutte d'eau
c'est tout à fait la goutte d'eau qui
fait déborder le vase
ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les publics
emerson
ce qui peut sembler excentrique ne
serait ce qu'avec sa coiffure
ont considéré qu'il ne faisait pas
partie des élus
s'est vite s'agissait de quelqu'un
de simple avec lequel vais boire une
bière mais avec la pandémie
on s'est rendu compte que ce type de
personne n'est pas du tout à briller
pour diriger le pays comme sommes pas la
situation est devenue si graves
qu'ils cherchent autour de lui n'importe
qui à qui faire bloquer à elle porter le
chapeau
le plus il fait cela de plus en colère
les gens
il ya encore beaucoup de personnes dans
les pays qui pensent que c'est un jour
en premier le ministre kylie a fait un
très bon travail avec le brigitte par
exemple et par la paix grâce à la
campagne de vaccination mais ces
arguments commencent à s'user et la
population commence à être lassé
de nombreuses personnes
témoigner que ne pas avoir pu dire leurs
adieux à des proches alors qu'il
m'aurait
moment même où barrézienne cinq minutes
se faisait la fête donc le public on a
assez et c'est qu'il s'en aille alors il
ya néanmoins une opération qui a été
lancée en opération cette big dog a
autrement dit opération sauver le gros
chien est ce que ça peut fonctionner
nom
de l'opération sauvé le gros chien c'est
que boris johnson essaie de sauver sa
peau en d'autres temps le cherche à
faire porter le chapeau à quelqu'un
d'autre là le premier candidat c'est
martin reynolds smith et tester des
principales qui a envoyé un email à des
centaines de personnes les invitant à
une rencontre sociale attendu street
où lé rencontrer les était interdite
martin reynolds n'aurait pas
l'accord explicite de personnes il
semblerait que martine raynaud ce risque
d'être viré pour cela mais boris johnson
essaye de plats mais d'autres personnes
l'ont le plus le studio est en colère
contre lui car il n'acceptait pas ses
responsabilités
même si on peut dire je me suis excusé
mais à mon sens un grand nombre de ces
excuses n'étaient pas sincères
il s'agissait pour lui souvent de venir
vous avez pensé que photo que de
s'excuser pour ses actions
suffisant donc je pense qu'il papilles
et la question est qui va le remplacer
je parti conservateur a sans doute
quelques candidats linda mais jusqu'à ce
qu'il soit remplacé il continuera tant
bien que mal en tant que premier
ministre à suivre donc merci à leicester
jones professeur agrégé en politique
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir